Transcriber:
Now to start off today, I want everyone
in here to close their eyes
and think about the first thing you saw
this morning when you opened your eyes.
You know, was it
that stain on your ceiling
that you keep putting off cleaning?
Was it your partner’s face
or your child jumping on top of you?
Or was it the morning rays of the sun
just creeping in through the blinds,
that mixture of pink, orange and yellow
that signifies the start of a new day.
Keep your eyes shut
just for a moment longer.
And imagine waking up now,
but instead of those beautiful images,
all you could see is
what you're seeing right now.
Darkness.
Those thoughts, those images
of the first thing you saw this morning
being exactly what it is now,
just a memory,
an image conjured
by your brain from your past.
Now open your eyes.
When I asked people what the one sense
that they couldn't live without is
most people immediately say, their sight.
And you can understand why that is.
I mean, our vision and what we see
play such an integral role in
how we perceive the world around us.
Just look at how much
we spend on buildings,
on parks, on architecture,
on things just to please our visual sense.
But what if we can't see?
What if we lose this gift?
What if slowly but surely,
your visual field
looks something like this?
Well, this is exactly what happens
in age-related
macular degeneration, or AMD.
This disease is the leading cause
of blindness in the developed world.
This disease affects one in seven
New Zealanders over the age of 50,
and yet the most common form
of this disease has no cure.
AMD is a serious problem.
But we think we have something
that may just be the solution
because of tiny molecules called microRNA
that are incredibly powerful
gene regulators.
But first, let's talk a little bit
about how we actually see.
Now that is just
a stunning structure, isn't it?
I could stare at it forever,
which is ironic because
that's what allows me to do so.
This is a retina.
This is the thing that allows us
to absorb light bouncing off of objects.
to define shapes, define edges.
This is what allows us to see.
It lines the back of the eye
and is multilayered,
with each layer containing cells
with its own respective role.
Now the cell type I want you
to know about today are photoreceptors.
And if you break down the word
and figure out what they mean,
photo, meaning light,
and receptors, or something that receives.
So they receive the light.
So when the light comes into our eye,
it's received by these cells
and through a series of processes
begins to convert it
into an electrical signal
that has been sent to the brain.
Eventually, this will form an image.
This is the first step to our vision,
to everything we see,
to you looking at me right now.
Now there's a specialized region
within the retina known as the macula.
It's approximately
5 millimeters in diameter
and houses another even more specialized
region known as the fovea.
Now when the light comes into our eye,
it's concentrated to focus
on this region of the retina.
It's responsible for pretty much
all of our useful day to day vision,
from our color perception
to our high visual detail,
to our central vision.
All of this mediated by this tiny region.
This is also the region
where your photoreceptors begin to die
if you have AMD.
In fact, a 1.5-millimeter
lesion in this area,
which is approximately
the thickness of a credit card,
will render you legally blind.
Unfortunately, AMD
is an incredibly complex disease,
and what this means is
if you try and block a single thing
leading to the disease,
it's very likely that something else
would just come and take its place.
Whether that be well establish causes,
such as inflammation or oxidative stress,
or things we just
don't even know about yet.
It's the same issue that faces researchers
looking into treatments
for all kinds of
neurodegenerative diseases,
such as Alzheimer's or Parkinson's.
But what if we could find one therapy
that could treat multiple causes?
You know, what if we could
get to the root of the disease?
Well, maybe we can, but to get there,
we need to understand
just a little bit about genetics.
Now some of you may be familiar
with the famous Watson, Crick and Wilkins,
who in many ways were the pioneers
of DNA as we know it.
I'm sure a lot of you
will also be familiar
with Steven Spielberg's
epic movie "Jurassic Park."
Remember that scene
where they have a preserved mosquito
with dinosaur’s blood in it,
and they use that to create new dinosaurs
and probably the coolest
yet most dangerous theme park of all time.
Well, a lot of you
probably scoffed at that idea,
but in some ways, genetically speaking,
it's actually true.
As Francis Crick said, DNA makes RNA,
RNA makes protein, and protein makes us.
This is the central dogma of genetics.
You can think of DNA as the code,
coding for just about everything about us,
so it makes us human
and not a monkey, a rat or a dog.
So it makes us unique individuals.
It's what makes us who we are,
but it is just the code.
So without the other components
of this central dogma,
it's just going to sit there
like a book waiting to be read.
Knowledge from this book
just waiting to be implemented.
Now your RNA are your messengers
responsible for bringing some of that code
and telling our cells,
OK, this is what needs
to be produced right now.
Then the protein that's made
is your functional component,
or your workers, if you will.
You can actually think
of this central dogma
as Swedish flatpack furniture giant IKEA.
Think of the IKEA warehouse as your DNA,
containing all of the code,
all the instructions for how
these pieces of furniture will be made,
but nothing is actually assembled yet.
You choose what you need
and you come out of the warehouse
with a set of instructions
for your furniture.
The set of instructions is your RNA,
copies and copies of these instructions,
leaving the warehouse, telling us exactly
how we assemble these pieces of furniture.
Then the fully functional furniture,
whether it be your wardrobe or a couch,
that's your protein, all assembled,
ready to do what they need to do.
DNA makes RNA, RNA makes protein,
and protein makes us.
Now when we talk
about a standard gene therapy,
you're often looking at a single target.
So gene therapies are fantastic
for diseases that can be attributed
to a single gene mutation
or single root cause.
But for a disease like AMD,
where there's multiple possible causes,
it's just not as useful
at this point in time.
But there's another type of RNA
called microRNA.
And instead of coding
for the creation of protein,
these microRNA can actually control
which RNA are being read.
They are incredibly powerful molecules,
with a single microRNA having the ability
to control up to 200 different targets
in what is known as negative regulation.
What this means is
that when it binds to an RNA,
it stops it from being read
and the protein from being produced.
So let's go back to IKEA.
Imagine microRNA as an officer
roaming the car park of IKEA,
checking everything
that's coming out of the warehouse
for a particular type of furniture.
Now notice I say type.
This is what I mean by a pathway.
So let's say we're suffering
from a coffee table epidemic
where people are just
cluttering their living rooms
with coffee tables upon coffee tables
upon coffee tables for no apparent reason.
Now IKEA will sell hundreds
of different kinds of coffee tables,
but they're all still coffee tables
serving the same general function.
A microRNA officer will recognize this
and specifically get rid
of all coffee table instructions.
Doesn't matter the shape,
the size or the color.
If it’s a coffee table,
the instructions will no longer be read,
and it will no longer be assembled.
This is how microRNA work.
They can regulate multiple genes
from the same pathway,
and this is why they are so powerful
because we now have the ability
to control an entire pathway
rather than a single gene on it.
MicroRNA have only really been discovered
since the turn of the century,
and yet there are already
multiple microRNA-based therapeutics
and clinical trials
for complex diseases such as cancer.
This shows their potential.
This shows their rapidness
in going from the lab bench
to the clinical bedside.
So let's recap.
We have an incredibly complex disease
known as age-related macular degeneration,
or AMD.
A disease that affects the central vision
with the most common form
having no known cure or treatment.
We have DNA, code that makes us us.
We have RNA messengers
for the creation of protein,
and then we have microRNA,
controllers of this process.
So in order to decide
which microRNA might be effective in AMD,
we used a technique
that allowed us to figure out
all of the active microRNA in the retina
and the targets they're controlling.
Using this technique,
we found there’s a particular microRNA
known as microRNA-124,
our hero of the story.
124 was far and wide
the most abundant and active microRNA
that we found in the retina.
It's definitely playing a role.
In fact, we found that it's playing
an anti-inflammatory role.
This is one of the pathways
that it acts on.
So it controls the production
of highly inflammatory molecules
when the retina gets too stressed.
124 is strong.
It's a great worker,
helps the greater good.
Exactly like a hero should.
So we looked in the retinas
of AMD patients
and what we found was this.
124, stained in red,
was completely absent
from the central retina of AMD patients
compared to a healthy individual.
Completely.
Remember the part of your retina
responsible for pretty much
all of our useful vision?
Well, 124 is missing there.
And this is what we think is happening.
124 is the most active
microRNA in the retina,
meaning that it's working a lot
even in a disease state,
fighting off danger molecules,
inflammatory molecules
that will cause even more harm.
Now the retina recognizes this
and activates more and more of our 124.
However, the retina
eventually gets overwhelmed.
Tragically, our heroes
can no longer keep fighting
and start dying off
to the point where they are
completely absent.
Exactly like we see in those AMD patients.
The enemies keep coming.
124, though, no more, missing in action.
And as a consequence, our retina suffers.
Our vision suffers.
So in a study we published last year,
we supplemented 124 to animals
that have undergone retinal damage.
And through an injection
of these molecules into the eye,
what we saw was that animals
receiving the treatment
had better retinal function,
had less photoreceptor cell death
and had less inflammation.
These are preliminary experiments
but a very promising start at that.
Our next step is to carefully analyze
all of the targets
that this 124 acts to control.
And we're also particularly interested
in how it is that these microRNA
travel in the retina
as a form of communication between cells.
Now what do I mean by this?
Well, we mainly focused on photoreceptors,
but the retina is
an interconnected network,
with every cell contributing
to its overall function.
In this same study,
we found that 124 moves
from the photoreceptor cells
to another cell type,
but only after the retina is damaged.
Too often we kind of look
at what's happening in the cells,
completely forgetting
there's actually a space in between them.
So if we can harness this
and discover how and why
these microRNA move between cells,
then we can engineer a deliverable vehicle
to transport the microRNA that we want
exactly where we want it.
Now I want everyone
to have a look at this image again.
And imagine living the rest of your life
with vision like this.
So next time you're with your loved ones,
study their faces, their every feature.
Next time you wake up in the morning,
pay attention to every single detail
of what you're seeing.
Use that gift of sight
and cherish these memories.
Because as I said,
one in seven of you will lose this ability
if nothing is done about this disease.
With an aging demographic
in current times,
our society seems to be
very concerned about living longer
and extending our lifespan.
But this is so wrong.
Trust me when I say this.
Longevity is not the answer.
Quality is the answer.
It's not about --
(Applause)
It's not about how long we can live, no.
It's about how long we can live well.
And with the use of microRNA
our hope and our goal
is that for millions of people,
this image can become clearer
for longer.
Thank you.
(Applause)